sí
sir isaac newton observó que los objetos
que están en reposo permanecen así a
menos que se les aplique una fuerza
y los objetos que están en movimiento
tienen una velocidad invariante por
ejemplo si una partícula flotará en un
espacio vacío no se detendría nunca así
pues ya sea que nuestra partícula esté
en reposo o viaje a una velocidad
constante si no aplicamos ninguna fuerza
sobre ella no habrá cambio en su
velocidad a eso se le llama la primera
ley de newton para acelerar nuestra
particular
esto es para cambiar su velocidad
debemos aplicar una fuerza neta como
sucede con la velocidad y la aceleración
las fuerzas también son vectores por
ejemplo la fuerza ocasionada por la
gravedad apuntará hacia abajo y su
longitud dependerá de cuánta gravedad
haya si la fuerza gravitacional es la
única fuerza que actúa sobre la
partícula
entonces su velocidad cambiará lo que
significa que la partícula acelerará en
dirección al vector de fuerza pero qué
sucede en múltiples fuerzas actuando
sobre la partícula por ejemplo si
sumamos la fuerza del viento a la fuerza
de la gravedad
supongamos que el viento sopla hacia la
derecha con la mitad de la fuerza de
gravedad que apunta hacia abajo entonces
necesitamos sumar estas fuerzas mediante
una suma de vectores para determinar la
fuerza neta escrita como una ecuación la
fuerza neta es igual a la gravedad más
el viento puesto que la fuerza neta
apunta hacia abajo y a la derecha
esto también indica la dirección hacia
la cual acelerará la partícula si hay
más fuerzas actuando tendremos que
sumarlas todas para determinar la fuerza
neta y eso determinará la dirección
hacia la cual acelerará a la partícula
por ejemplo supongamos que la partícula
está sobre una mesa la gravedad la jala
hacia abajo y el viento la empuja hacia
la derecha como en el ejemplo anterior
pero también hay otra fuerza que actúa
sobre la partícula la mesa la empuja
hacia arriba como una fuerza que se
opone a la gravedad así que nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas tiene este aspecto
las fuerzas de la gravedad y de la mesa
se anulan entre sí con lo que queda la
fuerza del viento como la fuerza neta
viene en el siguiente ejercicio
practicarás trabajando con fuerzas netas